il y a un an
barbara faisait des adieux à l'olympia
elle voulait tenter autre chose
après un essai au théâtre elle reprendra
dans quelques jours le tour de chant
cependant elle refuse d'y voir le
constat d'un échec
nous
il
fait mal à
endormi un soudain
sûr j'étais nulle part surgit le noir
bah non c'est votre appartenance
j'annonce que j'ai ordonné une système
une manière de travailler
j'ai jamais dit que je quittais la scène
et la porsche qui partit au moment où
les choses allaient mieux pour moi si
vous voulez j'ai lancé cette chose-là ce
moment nous dira constat d'échec de quoi
je vais voulu changer vous avez voulu
laisser la chanson non non je n'ai pas
laissé la chanson j'ai abandonné une
façon de travailler qui était justement
une espèce de fonctionnariat commun
fonctionnariat j'ai dit je ne veux plus
faire tous les ans et is tous les ans
musique qu il revient tous les ans du
même ville à la même heure mais ça je ne
veux pas parce que finalement une fête
de malhonnêteté qui s'installent plus de
facilité j'ai dit je ne veux pas
continuer je recommence et faire autre
chose alors je fais pièce et je
recommencerai sûrement sur une pièce
maintenant je chante
et puis voilà c'est à dire que je fais
ce que j'ai envie de faire comme j'ai
envie de le faire mais en quoi ce que
vous allez faire la différence du
système que vous refuser un but
différent parce qu'au moment où j'ai
balancé ça je n'avais absolument aucune
idée de chanson et pas du tout chansons
nouvelles et pas du tout envie d'écrire
des chansons et la gt chansons nouvelles
j'écris les chansons lors déjà ciblé
c'est différent dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui avec survêtement nouvelle
différencie parce que
c'est le cas par ex il est vraiment
temps que j'ai passé au cabaret et puis
que j'ai envie de chanter j'ai pu alors
dans la chanson qu'est ce que vous allez
faire et ne pas faire du tout y'a pas de
voix je parle de ma façon de faire mais
si charles ya pas de loin se passer on
peut tout faire vous savez on peut tout
faire
si on est sa propre vérité on peut tout
faire ce qui est important c'est de ne
pas tricher et de continuer à être
amoureux de ne pas croire on peut tout
faire
j'ai senti aussi que le public était
sous santé si vous voulez avait santé
fruste frustré ou tristes au ça je ne
veux pas je ne veux pas